[موسيقى]
مع أكثر من 94000 وافد إلى إيطاليا معًا
إلى المراحل الأخرى من الدخول الأول إلى
تتحمل أوروبا العبء الأكبر
لحماية الحدود الأوروبية
التعامل مع الاتجار بالبشر
في البحر الأبيض المتوسط
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذا هو بالضبط ما فعلته أوروبا
معاهدة مع تركيا أردوغان 6
مليار + 3 9 مليار يورو
ساهمت إيطاليا ببعض
مائة مليون لوقف
طريق البلقان ليس من الواضح لماذا
لا ينبغي لأوروبا أن تمد يدها
لإيطاليا للدفاع عن تلك القطعة من
الحدود الخارجية للاتحاد الأوروبي التي
إنهم يتطلعون إلى البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​يفعلون ما يفعلونه
هناك أيضا التعامل مع حكومة الله
[موسيقى]
الناتج المحلي الإجمالي في إيطاليا لم ينمو ولكن
إبقاء الناس على متن السفن الفقر
لم يتضاءل في إيطاليا بالوصم
المهاجرون
[موسيقى]